hidey-ho reject nation I'm Greg Alba no
I'm John we watched Hellboy 2019 I read
Hellboy the Wild Hunt very very recently
I know this movie is primarily inspired
by I think three specific Hellboy
stories from Mike Mignola yeah there's
like a three book I think I read the
middle one it was cool watching this
movie because there were scenes for sure
and in terms of like designs the
aesthetic that were just straight-up
ripped from the comics but then there's
also just dialogue and just full-on
scenes that are like oh that's exactly
what I read last week for me that was
like yeah that's pretty cool to see
brought to life and if you're a big fan
of the comics I mean that's gonna be
gratifying either way I do have a slight
bias with a very very slight bias that I
feel I should just acknowledge because
some people have already heard me talk
about him before I know the man Joel
Harlow the man Joe Harlow
he's the guy who did the new makeup for
Hellboy like not just how boy himself
the special character design but also
all the practical effects involved this
film having some inside knowledge into
the movie I feel like I was more
properly prepped for this film than a
lot of other people I knew way well
going into this movie that it was going
to be a throwback to 80s monster horror
flicks kind of that b-movie grindhouse
esque
style infused in this film and knowing
some of Neil Marshalls past films every
time I hear the name Neil Marshall I was
talking about those Game of Thrones
episodes he's directed but you know he's
done stuff like Dog Soldiers the descent
he knows how to have like a lot of good
fun gory horror movies you know yeah
dude say stuff like that so I wasn't
surprised or taking it back by the kind
of film that we got I know on Rotten
Tomatoes right now the critics core is
not exceptionally high it's pretty low
but I know the audience score is
certified fresh' right now which is a
cool sign my personal experience of this
film is I think there's a lot of pros
and there's a lot of cons and funny
enough I did hear some Suicide Squad
comparisons to this movie prior to
watching it and watching this movie I
could see why in terms of like editing
music pacing how much story is involved
but I kind of had a opposite response
where a Suicide Squad I saw all those
flaws and I was like
you know it's still a fun movie and then
the more I thought about it the more I
really didn't like that movie it was one
of those films and Hellboy was like on
the opposite spectrum for me I walked
out and I was thinking a lot about the
flaws that I had with the film this
morning especially was thinking about
last night and then this morning I slept
over at my girlfriend Olivia's place and
I came back here one of the first thing
that told John was the Hellboy movies
really growing on me a hell of a lot I
find that there's a lot of things I
really did enjoy about this movie so I
wanted to talk about those elements
first and then we'll go into the
constants I actually told Joel Mike this
is one of those things were like for
every con there's a pro for every pro
that's kind of a con to you a mixed bag
but I'm finding that the pros for me are
really outweighing the cons that I had
for the film I had a similar experience
to you with the Suicide Squad comparison
of yeah coming out of Suicide Squad I
was like oh that's fun but then it
deteriorated very fast in my mind and I
think part of that is because Suicide
Squad when you think about just the
construction of the plot it's like you
realize that there's some nonsense in
there that wouldn't have worked anyway
at least in the form the story has taken
whereas in this movie if you smooth some
things out the story itself still works
yeah that's the key for starters David
Harbor as Hellboy I thought did a really
really good job you can really
differentiate the differences between
Ron Perlman's interpretation and David
harbor's interpretation cuz David Harbor
brings this level of childlike
insecurity kind of like a boy who's been
hurt sort of quality underneath you know
like an adolescent or like a teenager
with some angst to work out you know
he's got issues with his dad and stuff
like that which is a running theme in
the movie
yeah and he's just at odds with his
position in the world as well as his
position you know hunting down
paranormal creatures and stuff I'm very
much relieved to be in the situation
where a lot of my issues that will go in
to come down to you know editing pacing
and some CGI which is not really that
great and in certain sequences right so
if I do any of those guys then I would
be like maybe we should just shoot a
review fortunately the guy who did all
the practical effects the practical
effects in this movie are amazing
and that seems to be all around the map
in terms of even a lot of people who are
not recommending this movie a lot of
people are still going but you know the
practical effects in here and the makeup
are still really damn good in the movie
and it sure does shine it's one of the
highlights of the movie like David
harbors performance and the makeup and
they kind of have to especially with the
Hellboy design that has to work together
really well
I know there was some backlash with the
first trailer in terms of how people
were responding to the makeup but when
you watch the movie you forget about
like oh it's David Harbor underneath all
that you quickly buy into it and it
feels very lived in as well as all the
other designs as well so those are like
the two main highlights also if you're a
person who heard this movies oh it's
r-rated I hear it's gonna be more
violent yeah it getting delivers on that
it is very very violent sometimes
shockingly violent there are certain
moments where my especially towards the
finale I won't give it away but there
are moments sort of tie where my jaw was
dropped they went there this feels like
I'm watching attack on Titan right now
this is so gory like hellish Silent Hill
style yes oh yeah
so it really delight that element
b-movie monster may have violence gore
you're gonna get that do you get a good
lead you do get a good lead and the
designs on this really cool and I feel
like with a lot of you know big-budget
comic book adaptations it's primarily
CGI reliant it was cool that the
practical effects in here in the makeup
are all really well done even though
I've only read 1/3 of the main books
that this is based off of it was really
cool to see how much of that was just
directly ripped and brought to the big
screen so I think for fans of the
Hellboy comics I can't speak in terms of
the whole the whole thing but from what
I can gather it feels pretty accurate
and this is why I think Mike Mignola was
you know backing this movie so much I
don't think either of us is like madly
attached to the del Toro versions and so
in that way this one is allowed to have
its own aesthetic which you know is
gonna have some reminiscent quality
because Hellboy is in it but yeah the
tone and what the movies going for is so
different yeah and yeah is tied in more
directly to the source material in terms
of just like a splattery action flick I
think there is a lot
to enjoy here because that's mainly the
flavor I got fantasy action with a lot
of gore in it I didn't necessarily feel
tense I didn't really feel like this was
a horror movie now which I arguably
could have maybe used a bit more of but
yeah generally speaking you know in
terms of an action movie especially I
feel like that's where this movie
delivers the most it feels more army of
Darkness less evil debt funny enough
army of Darkness was not well-received
what it first came out and I feel like
this could have a similar thing over
time as well I'm not so biased to the
point that I did not have issues with
the way a lot of this was actually
executed my main issue if I were to boil
down everything I'm about to talk about
falls under this one line which is I
could totally tell there was a longer
movie here I could feel some reshoots
and I could feel they really had to trim
it down which is a similar issue that
people felt with Suicide Squad yeah and
that was something that definitely would
come up for in my brain a good amount of
time when I was watching this movie was
I didn't think this movie was
necessarily the well-edited
I didn't think it was necessarily well
paced for every Pro there's a con for
every con there's a pro because
sometimes in that messiness it makes it
more fun sometimes it just really did
tracks you know yeah I mean there are
just a lot of edges on this movie for me
and yeah there are times when it just
gets mired with choppy editing and
choppy sound cues that just kind of call
attention yeah so a weird ADR yeah there
are a lot of lines that are kind of
thrown out there like and covered in
coverage and stuff like that and after a
certain point there are times where I
personally was just really reminded I'm
watching a movie right now and I'm kind
of aware that this is all assessed so
some of those things do break the
illusion however I do think that there
are sequences in this movie had moments
in this movie you know vignettes at
least the dude translate I was kind of
in and out of the movie a lot but there
are times where I was absorbed in and I
was laughing or I was you know excited
for some kind of action right piece and
I mean like another Suicide Squad
parallels this movie is like crammed
full of like popular music half the time
it's like there's 20 seconds of like
some some loud metal song and that'll be
the transition for everything yes
sometimes there
works and sometimes it undercuts a lot
of what could be a real tense scene or
real scene where you're just pulled in
by the emotional gravitas there are
times we're really just undercuts the
effect that scene can actually have and
I feel like sometimes the soundtracks
that are used are meant to smooth out
some of that choppy editing kind of just
draws attention it's kind of a drawback
to the teenage heavy-metal vibe yeah
half the time it works and half the time
you're like oh maybe just turn it down
yeah yeah score piece going in yeah I
think to that you know some complaints
I've heard that's over stuff and there
are times where I did feel like yeah
there's too many plot lines in here the
con there's so many plot lines in here
the pro in that mess but I found myself
weirdly feeling when I woke up it's kind
of cool that you could have sort of got
this wide variety collection of all
different kinds of creatures and
storylines sort of shoved in here
because this script is a heavily
expositional it's a very very
expositional a very plot heavy but like
I said when I read The Wild Hunt I'm
like that's pretty much how the Wild
Hunt is that's the weird and sometimes
directly adapting a comic straight from
the pages does not necessarily mean it
translates well to the screen because I
can just communicate as being overly
expositional and stuff so that's why my
brain is like half criticism half
forgiving because I'm like yeah when I
read the comic oh yeah that's pretty
much where the debate about comic-book
accuracy does enter into my mind because
on the one hand yeah I'm like oh cool
like you know this is actually part of
it but for the terms of dialog and story
exposition I feel like you're making the
jump like you're restricted in a comic
to a panel that won't move so you could
only put a few bits of information in
each one whereas in a movie yeah that's
just not the case it's like one there
will be people who are fans of the comic
who really like that in this movie
because it's it's very much like the
comic none of the others really like
what's a different medium so it doesn't
translate necessarily well with that the
way the movie is not necessarily edited
super well the pacing is not so great
while a lot of that is made up in a lot
of fun monster mayhem I feel it does
undercut a lot of
that casts performances because
individually the performances were
really good I thought you McShane did a
really good job David Harbour day I'll
take him I thought they all did a really
good job but because of the way the
movie was edited the shared chemistry
doesn't really get to shine if that
makes sense
individually I see you're committed I
know you guys are all great actors and
you guys are definitely delivering on
what you're supposed to do but because
of the way the film is chopped together
their chemistry doesn't get to shine
yeah it's like I liked everybody who was
there I could see all the potential and
yeah just for whatever reason a lot of
things came out personally it came out
flat for me the tone gets lost for me a
lot in this movie and that kind of
hampers the character chemistry too it
leaves you with kind of not a lot to
latch into but a lot to kind of hope for
yeah I like the idea of everybody and I
like what's being presented to me I just
wish it was in a different packaging or
it had a different finesse on top of it
it's like I wanted to see this movie
re-edited with the same people and the
same elements you know I really feel
like the main issue is the editing a
huge issue it's like there are like
other issues like yeah this script could
have been definitely fine-tuned but I
also feel like a lot of this script was
sort of redone because of the way the
movies edited and looking at all the
images I'm looking at everything that's
on screen I could feel the Edit down and
I'm like I bet there's a really really
just a movie that generally would have
been perceived as really good if it had
a different kind of cut you know I
really get that impression yeah and
maybe if it lets some of the I guess I
harp on this a lot but if it lets some
character beats breathe or something
because the movie does start to get this
cacophonous very shrill pace going where
you're just kind of lurching from one
event to the next and like character
motivations and things that should be
pretty challenging especially for
Hellboy as a character certain internal
struggles he's going through kind of
feel random and start to feel sort of
underserved and out of nowhere and
everything in the context starts to feel
like a jumble so like the action saves a
lot but the context is just kind of
flavorless after a while it's just kind
of shrill and noisy I'll say I don't
think it deserves a 12 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes I think while there's a lot of
flaws in this movie there's also a lot
of really cool things in this movie
there's gonna be some audience members
where the really cool thing
we'll ultimately outweigh the flaws
either by no means think this is a
flawless film I don't think anybody is
going to 100% on ironically and just
enjoy this but I did have a thought
halfway partway through the movie where
I was thinking I could see how you would
really hate this I can also see how you
might have a blast way yeah exactly
because like there are times when you're
gonna laugh on purpose there are times
when you're gonna laugh or something
maybe not on purpose but sometimes that
can help like we said earlier that
there's like CGI elements in here that
just don't quite work I liked it for the
most part when it was used to enhance
certain practical designs but then
there's also elements here where I'm
just like that just does not look very
good the times I thought the CG worked
there's a character near at grocock
who's in the comic his design was really
cool I thought it was it more
interesting villain than actually Nimoy
well yeah it's like she really showed up
for the role but yeah like drew is just
so much more compelling villain his
backstories we're interesting yeah he's
got actual personal yeah like that's
what I mean the secondary villain is
really interesting and even more
menacing in some ways he has a certain
murder scene that's like really
disturbing Nym way is pretty much a
generic villain Mia Jovovich is doing
her absolute best to elevate it she's
yeah it's a mixed bag for me I
ultimately weigh in the direction of I
enjoyed this and I don't think it's as
bad as everyone made it out to be I feel
like if you unplug and just you know
release yourself to a fun b-movie
monster mayhem romp then I think you'll
have a good time but then I could also
see why some people just really won't
like it like you said some people gonna
hate this somebody were gonna have a
total blast with this I'm meeting people
who were on both sides of those bags you
know yeah and for me I mean ultimately I
fall in the middle I think this movie is
a mess in a lot of ways but hey some of
that mess like you said is enjoyable
there are moments that did grab me and
that did pull me in and and yeah I think
ultimately if they just gave some
breathing room to the cut maybe added
some things back in this could have been
much smoother alright guys well did you
see how boy what did you think of it do
you agree with the critics are you more
on that certified fresh' audience score
put it in the comments below you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification
Asian Bell will catch you guys soon